depuis le début du mois chaque fin de
semaine nous vous avons présenté des
centres de loisirs installé près de chez
vous pour le dernier relais de cette
série nous irons ce soir dans une base
qui connaît quelques problèmes celle de
créteil jean claude et jacques
s'étendant sur une superficie de 43
hectares la base de créteil est la seule
base de loisirs existantes dans le val
demain les équipements mis à disposition
du public sont des plus complets 30
optimiste 25 420 soit un total de plus
de 100 d'embarcations pédalos et barques
comprise
une surveillance y est exercée en
permanence en effet n'est pas rare
d'enregistrer sur ce plan d'eau des
vents de force 6 à 7 pour les débutants
une école de voile dispense des cours
théoriques qui leur permettent de
prendre la mer après une heure
d'enseignement seulement
une grande absence sur cette base la
pratique de la planche à voile
déconseillée par un arrêté préfectoral
un examen de l'école normale supérieure
de zoologie en effet révélé dans ce lac
un haut degré de pollution
le plan d'eau a été aménagé sur une
ancienne sablière
ainsi les zoophiles 30 entretiennent une
pollution quasi permanente
à cela vient s'ajouter le branchement
sauvage d'égout sur deux bouches
d'alimentation 12 pour l'instant cette
pollution est égale à 10% du volume des
eaux du lac
mais ce chiffre ne peut aller qu'en
augmentant si la préfecture et les
services municipaux peuvent agir sur la
deuxième cause en revanche la première
raison pourrait à long terme condamner
l'existence de cette base quoi qu'il en
soit la création d'une piscine d'eau
traitée évite tous les dangers pour les
baigneurs éventuelles